the dive team is hoping to find a tavern
where Morgan himself might have had a
drink if I can't find anything over
thanks to that have a good one
okay this a turbine in here is pretty
pretty dance let's see where are we
where we are I still get that quite sure
I hate to be over-optimistic though I do
feel good about this one
Shh yeah we're just breaking out the mic
now we can actually see something again
we're close another bricks and
structured stones in a finance it
suggests that I'm very nearly in the
vicinity
Molly's hips have found something
oh man so insane
this is really a sick tacular
spectacular views
finally a lost world reveals itself
see how destructive earthquake was this
part of the buildings and all the job of
the walls collapsed falling over this
wall also has something of a wavy
appearance probably result not only of
the earthquake but it before the water
striking this structure it's really a
thrill to be right at this location once
again kind of a dream
this building would have been about two
stories high most of that brick when
it's fallen in and on top of everything
look in the room
small version of buildings in water
seated London at the time step Allah for
oil would it look like a miniature scale
London
please the see while these bricks still
in order
despite the earthquake they didn't lose
their integrity they stayed in a really
nice tight bond it's really exciting to
see this